have gone brosman is very bad today were
playing the search it's set just like
Dark Souls the search is a sci-fi Dark
Souls sci-fi Dark Souls the search the
search is a sci-fi Dark Souls game the
search continuing the Dark Soul the
precession but it's Samar listen here
you [ __ ] it ain't [ __ ] dark so
sweet [ __ ] duck call again
really [ __ ] annoying and you know
it's not oh look it's just like Dark
Souls he died Wow
the search has souls like a combat but
its best approach from a blood-borne
state of man autism is nothing to be
ashamed of stop it good to know can you
fit a [ __ ] pig can you fit someone in
the [ __ ] ass in the search apparently
there's a Twitter account just based on
this this looks like Zelda me Dark Souls
Gandhi said that code rain looks like an
anime vampire version of Dark Souls
it's the anime Dark Souls oh oh
okay okay well maybe I was wrong maybe
they just have a no penetration that's
fine you know what actually now I really
want to play the game all the sudden oh
[ __ ] this menu screen is just like Dark
Souls and I got a save system that's
just like Dark Souls got an increase
what is the sequence like what's
happening what is it oh my god I am
handicapped hell yeah whoa Game of the
Year it's just like oh yeah already what
a [ __ ] [ __ ] game wow this is gonna
be a challenge just like that okay there
can go here okay well hi a guy next to
me does anyone know where the handicap
ramp is ah
it crashed just like no wait that Dark
Souls doesn't crash okay well whatever
are you kidding me you're kidding me
what is this game won from me oh thank
god a handicap ramp come on man all
right so here we are in the game just
like Dark Soul really oh my god just
like dog sauce I can block yes
hey you got nut that [ __ ] out
okay well so far I haven't died yet so
this game is nothing like Darko's yeah
is that potato chip and they're called
TechCrunch just like duck so good to see
you
how it's one of those
good to see you too oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's
like a zombie make a dude oh [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] man chill understand
just like Dark Souls there that that
[ __ ] okay well that was cool and all but
can I jump again
my god that was fantastic look at that
jump Hey
so happy so cute
alright here is another one now Africa
hey buddy that's [ __ ] right there are
deaths everyone I've never died good
game good game everyone can we anally
mr. Smith oh oh [ __ ] he looks strong to
[ __ ] eat oh my god
[Music]
yes there that I'm really long health
[ __ ] sake
oh let's cut that out
strike enemies to be loved energy then
hold X to perform finishing moves oh
that's awesome
well that didn't work
oh yeah oh my load that's some kinky
[ __ ] my man that makes me want to that
makes me want to jump on my left eye
that's some sexy [ __ ] of our boss what's
the [ __ ] beeping thing I beeps when a
mere item well that's not annoying at
all none from look I made it in gasps oh
look at that guy oh [ __ ] he's gonna fly
oh [ __ ] he came he came out of nowhere I
did the jump don't worry about it how do
I look I forgot stop
well whatever there are death whatever I
don't care
okay all right this time I'm going to be
so super careful for the phone
Oh oh my eat jumps he's cheating
he's got damn it again edit that out for
[ __ ] sake
god dammit I'm not like dog soldiers
please [ __ ] hey we're going up everyone
top of the mountain to you man this game
is so easy my god even this game I have
ever played I can't believe I oh [ __ ] I
can't believe I never died incredible I
know what you're asking yourself how
easy so can this [ __ ] beeping thing
just the [ __ ] oh I hit me twice oh
[Music]
hell no
man those bushes are honestly just like
dog shows incredible all right I never
went oh my god it's drones shame on you
this is just like real life
I wonder what music I'm listening to in
those headphones I wonder if I can get
robot butt implants that'd be [ __ ]
awesome
well let's remove the [ __ ] climax
robot thing Jesus Christ I was annoying
oh my god oh whoa I could run run run
just shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] up there were two against one
I mean [ __ ] how do I die against these
two [ __ ] morons
I mean I didn't I didn't we almost got
it Wow the robots in the future are
incredibly intelligent
Wow it's just amazing how are they going
to destroy us how are we going to
survive the future I mean they're too
smart
how are they possibly good game just
like Dark Souls
what the [ __ ] was that
are you impossible
he has no idea is that zero [ __ ]
death God [ __ ] smash there you go and a
jump nailed it there - everyone thank
you
I want to thank my mom especially for
never killing me appreciate your mom
oh my god it was a trap I'm up I'm done
I'm [ __ ] done with this game I'm so
[ __ ] done it crashed I can't believe
it hours of gameplay just [ __ ] gone
just like dark so why can't we be
friends why can't we be friends why
can't we be friends why can't we be
friends
[Music]